WE CAN MEANING ARE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET. FOR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
REMAINDER OF THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET PACKAGE TRAILER BILLS.
WE'RE GOING TO COMMENCE WITH S.
B. EIGHT FOUR TWO OUR EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL.
THIS COST.
CAPTAIN YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
VICE CHAIR MEMBERS IN THE COST
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
FIRST BILL HIGH IS THE EDUCATION
HIGH ON THE BUS TRAILER BILL
WHICH AMONG OTHER PROVISIONS.
PROVIDES THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS TO FULLY FUND
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA.
PROVIDE SIX HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
MILLION IN ONE TIME
DISCRETIONARY GRANTS WITH AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
APPROPRIATED IN THE BUDGET BILL
AND SEPARATE TRAILER BILL
LEGISLATION.
PROVIDES THREE HUNDRED MILLION
IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR THE LOW
PERFORMING STUDENTS BLOCK GRANT
WHICH IS ALLOCATED TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BASED ON STUDENTS WITH
LOW TEST SCORES THAT ARE NOT
OTHERWISE PROVIDED.
TARGETED FUNDING BY THE STATE OR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LOOKING TOWARDS ARE VERY FULL
COMMITTEE WERE SAYING THIRTY
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON SB EIGHT FOUR THREE
HIGHER EDUCATION.
THANK YOU THIS IS THE HIGHER
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL AND AMONG
THE PROVISIONS THE BILL
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA ON MY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO SERVE LOW
WAGE WORKING ADULTS.
THE BILL ESTABLISHES A NEW
STUDENT FOCUSED FUNDING FORMULA
TO ALLOCATE APPORTIONMENT FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BUT THAT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU BEFORE I GO BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
ON S. B. EIGHT FOUR TWO
EDUCATION.
OUR EDUCATION TRAILER BILL.
NO MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC FOR OR
AGAINST OKAY THEN BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE ON S. B. EIGHT FOUR
THREE HIGHER EDUCATION.
OKAY SEEN NONE WILL GO TO SB A
FOR FOR HEALTH.
THANK YOU THIS BILL PROPOSES
VARIOUS STATUTORY CHANGES
RELATED TO THE MEDICARE PROGRAM
AND OTHER HEALTH PROGRAMS IN
THAT PART.
OF CARE SERVICES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
I HAD THE PROVISIONS OF THE BELL
ESTABLISHED THE DIVERSION FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL
DISORDERS PROGRAM AN OPTIONAL
FELONY OR MISDEMEANOR PRETRIAL
COUNTY DAY VERSION PROGRAM.
THAT ALLOWS LOCAL ENTITIES TO
COLLABORATE WITH COURTS TO
DIVERT DEFENDANTS WITH MENTAL
DISORDERS FROM THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM INTO COMMUNITY
TREATMENT.
THIS TRAILER BILL ALSO CREATE
THE COUNCIL ON HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS AN INDEPENDENT
BODY TO DEVELOP A PLAN WITH
OPTIONS FOR ACHIEVING A HEALTH
CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL ALSO CONTAINS --
OR ALLOWS FOR THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT TO CONVENE A REVIEW
COMMITTEE COMPOSED OF SEVEN TO
ELEVEN MEMBERS FROM THE HEALTH
CARE FIELD TO DEVELOP AT
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE
ESTABLISHMENT IMPLEMENTATION.
AND ONGOING ADMINISTRATION OF A
HEALTH CARE COST TRANSPARENCY
DATABASE AND A PROVIDES THAT
WOULD HAPPEN WITHIN THE SIXTY
MILLION DOLLAR A ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION FOR
THAT PURPOSE.
THINKING THIS CONSTANT
[inaudible]
MR LIMITED.
MR OUTSIDE A QUESTION ABOUT THE
COUNCIL ON HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEMS SO YOU SAID THAT THEY
ARE GONNA BE TASKED WITH --
A PLAN FOR ACHIEVING UNIVERSAL
FINANCING FOR HEALTH CARE IN
CALIFORNIA I'M WONDERING IS AT
THE SAME DEBATE THAT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S BEEN HAVING ABOUT
SINGLE PAYER HEALTHCARE.
AMERICA'S SECOND FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
HEALTHCARE COUNCIL'S INTENT IS
TO STEP UP ITS ONE STEP TOWARDS
THAT DIRECTION BUT THIS IS A
MORE METHODICAL IN THAT OUR
INTENT THIS LIKE.
CONVENE THE CONCIL FURS AND SEE
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE OUT THERE AND
WHAT CHANGES WE SHOULD --
TAKE.
OKAY WELL WE'RE ALL AWARE THAT
THIS IS BUT A SUBJECT OF INTENSE
DEBATE IN THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
LAST YEAR AND I I JUST WANT.
TO GO ON RECORD AS SAYING I
THINK IT'S AN APPROPRIATE TO
ESTABLISH AN INDEPENDENT BUT
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCY TO
ESSENTIALLY HAVE THE DEBATE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN HAVING
--
I FIND THAT VERY PREMATURE.
THANK YOU MS FOX.
A COULD YOU CLARIFY WHO SERVES
ON THIS COUNCIL.
THE COUNCIL WILL BECOME PRICE OF
FIVE MEMBERS AND A THREE WILL BE
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR. ONE
WILL BE APPOINTED BY THE SPEAKER
OF THE ASSEMBLY AND ONE WILL BE
APPOINTED BY THE SENATE RULES ON
COMMITTEE AND AMONG THEMSELVES
THEY WILL RELATE IT ELECT A
CHAIR.
IS THERE CERTAIN CRITERIA
THEY'LL BE USED TO A POINT.
THAT IS YET TO BE OWN DETERMINE
BUT WE DON'T HAVE IT IN THE
STATUTE SPECIFIED.
SO THE SO EXCEPT WHEN THEY'RE
PROCESS THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
BODY AND THE GOVERNOR --
WITH CRITERIA STILL YET TO BE
DEVELOPED.
THANK YOU THE QUESTIONS.
AS COOPER.
I GOT IT MISTER CHAIR WAS WERE
ON A FOUR FOUR YES.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT --
THE MIDDLE HEALTH ASPECT.
IT WE JUST ALREADY AND I
APOLOGIZE THOSE LATE.
I BELIEVE YOU'RE REFERENCING THE
PROVISION AYE REGARDING THE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL.
YEAH IT IN THIS MY QUESTION IS
WELL OUT DIVERSION FOR SERIOUS
ABOUT FELONIES.
AND SEX OFFENSES.
I COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS EVEN EQUIPPED TO
DEAL WITH THESE INDIVIDUALS.
SB TWO FIFTEEN SETS UP THIS
EXACT PROGRAM THE LIMIT IS TWO
MISDEMEANORS. ELEVEN SEVENTY H.
FELONIES.
APARTMENT FINAL SOME SORT OF
WHAT.
SO WHILE THE DIVERSION FOR
SERIOUS OR VIOLENT FELONIES AND
SEX OFFENSES.
IT IS A COUNTY COURT TO DO IS
INDIVIDUALS.
AT YES THEY ARE SO THE WAY THAT
STRUCK THAT THE PROGRAM IS
STRUCTURED IS IT GIVES THE
COURTS THE DISCRETION --
TO MAKE A DETERMINATION WHETHER
OR NOT THIS INDIVIDUAL IS.
APPROPRIATE FOR PLACEMENT INTO
THE COMMUNITY.
SO PROGRESS INCLUDE LANGUAGE
PROVIDING FOR VICTIM RESTITUTION
EVEN IF SOMEONE RECEIVES
DIVERSION.
THE CURRENT CURRENTLY WRITTEN
THE TRIBBLES NOT PROVIDE FOR
VICTIMS TUITION.
WHY IS THIS THIS IS A VIOLATION
OF MARCY'S LAW?
SO YOU'RE CORRECT THE THE
LANGUAGE DOES NOT AT INCLUDE A
HAM.
RESTITUTION BUT THE LANGUAGE IS
THE LANGUAGE IS CRAFTED TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER DIVERSION
PROGRAMS THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
STATUTE.
THE VIOLATE MARCY'S LOS --
I MEAN I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN
ANSWER THAT QUESTION AND HELP.
OKAY BUT THEN THE MY LAST
QUESTION HER COUNTIES PREPARED
TO BE.
START DOING THIS TOMORROW
OBVIOUSLY.
SO THE PROGRAM THAT WAS
DEVELOPED WAS --
TO ESSENTIALLY --
LEVERAGE THE EXISTING PROGRAMS
THAT COUNTIES HAVE AVAILABLE SO
THERE ARE A LOT OF COUNTIES
COUNTIES IN WHICH THE PROGRAM
WAS ATTENDED THIS ITEM.
INTENDED --
TO PROBLEM.
BE PLACED IN IS IS A LOT OF THEM
HAVE MISDEMEANOR PROGRAMS IN
PLACE SO IT IS OUR UNDERSTANDING
THAT THEY HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
BEGIN DOING THIS --
BUT I WILL KNOW THAT THE FUNDING
THAT SPECIFIC FOR THIS PROGRAM
IS AVAILABLE OVER THREE YEARS TO
THE EXTENT THAT THEY ARE NOT
AVAILABLE. TO RAMP UP QUICKLY
THAT THEY HAVE A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME.
TO UTILIZE THESE FUNDS CREATES A
SCISSORS NO DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION IN THIS BILL IT
TAKES EFFECT ISN'T OF SIGN.
A SHOULD WE GIVE COLONEL JUSTICE
SYSTEM STAKEHOLDERS TIME TO
PREPARE FOR SUCH A MASSIVE SHIFT
IN HOW WE PLAY TREAT MENTALLY
ILL MURDERS.
AND RAPES IN THE COMMUNITY.
SO THEY WILL HAVE TIME TO
DEVELOP PLANS AND SUBMIT THEM TO
THE APARTMENT FOR
IMPLEMENTATION.
BUT THE BILL IS SINCE THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED IT TAKES EFFECT
THOUGH.
SO IT MEANS NO LAG TIME SO
YOU'RE CORRECT BUT THIS IS AN
OPTIONAL PROGRAM FOR COUNTIES TO
IMPLEMENT THIS IS NOT REQUIRED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
OKAY SEEN NONE I ANY MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC CONSERVE PART OF S. B..
EIGHT FOUR FOUR BETH COMPELLING
TO HAVE HEALTHAXIS CALIFORNIA WE
ARE PLEASED TO SEE THE FUNDING
FOR THE DATABASE WHICH WE WORKED
ON FOR OVER A DECADE NOW SO TO
SEE IT FUNDED IN THE CHANCE OF
IT BEING OPERATIONAL --
IS A GOOD THING WE ALSO ARE --
DISAPPOINTED THAT THERE IS NOT
FUNDING FOR EXPANDING COVERAGE
BUT PLEASED TO SEE THE STEPS
FORWARD TO FURTHER STUDY HOW TO
GET TO UNIVERSAL COVERAGE IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT.
MISTER CHAIR JONATHAN LYMAN AND
HAVE THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION
CALTRAIN COMMUTE CONSCIOUS I'M
WONDERING IF I COULD SPEAK ON
THE HIGHER READ BECAUSE I HEARD
YOU CALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
FOR THE EDUCATION BILL BUT NOT
THE HIGHER READ.
IF THAT WOULD BE OKAY ABSOLUTE
--
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
WE WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION FOR MONEY FOR FULL
AND PART TIME FACULTY AS WELL AS
MENTAL HEALTH.
AND THE ACADEMIC SENATE WITH THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION HEALTH WE
COMMUNICATE JUST WANTS TO GO ON
RECORD.
AS SAYING THAT WE ARE VERY
DISTRESSED.
AT THE FACT THAT THE OF THE
FINAL PRODUCT DOES NOT
SUFFICIENTLY INCORPORATE.
UP WHAT THE THE FINE WORK.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NEVER.
TO ON THE OUR ONLINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AS WELL AS THE FUNDING
FORMULA THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
STINGER INDULGENCE MISTER CHAIR
ON THE HIGHER ED.
THE BILL OF CHRISTY BROWN WILL
BE UP CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS EXTRAORDINARILY
PLEASED WITH THE ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION TO SUPPORT PASSED
A PER SHIP OUR TRAINING.
THAT WAS DELIVERED AND SOME OF
THE REPORTING LANGUAGE
CLARIFICATION WITH RESPECT TO
THE CHANGE OF HOW.
A PERSON COULD BE FUNDED UNDER
OF TS AND SO WE JUST THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INDULGENCE AND WE
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OUR OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION. TO S. B..
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TIFFANY MATTHEWS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
THERE'S ALREADY LEGISLATION IN
THE SECOND HOUSE S. B..
TWO FIFTEEN THAT ADDRESSES THIS
EXACT ISSUE AND REPRESENTS AN
AGREEMENT BY STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHY THIS POLICY
NEEDS TO BE DONE THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS.
WHAT WE SUPPORT THE IDEA OF
DIVERSION?
AIMED AT KEEPING WILL LEVEL
MENTALLY ILL OFFENDERS OUT OF
JAIL THIS BILL DOES NOT
ADEQUATELY PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS DIVERSION FOR
ALL OFFENSES UP TO AND INCLUDING
MURDER.
BECAUSE THIS IS A TRAILER BILL.
IT WOULD TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
UPON BEING SIGNED.
COUNTIES AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM STAKEHOLDERS ARE NOT
PREPARED FOR THIS DRASTIC CHANGE
IN DEALING WITH THIS POPULATION.
WE URGE THE IMPLEMENTATION BE
DELAYED UNTIL AT LEAST JANUARY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
LOOKING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEITHER MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
OPPOSED S. B. [inaudible]
EIGHT FOUR FOUR OKAY.
MOVING FORWARD S. B. EIGHT FOUR
FIVE HUMAN SERVICES.
THANK YOU THIS IS OUR HUMAN
SERVICES OMNIBUS BILL INCLUDES
SEVERAL PROVISIONS NOTABLY IT --
BUT IT INCLUDES THAT STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE ELIMINATION
OF THE CAST OUT CASH OUT POLICY
FOR SSI THAT RESULTS IN
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY NINE THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS.
BECOME NEWLY ELIGIBLE FOR CAL
FRESH BENEFITS AND FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS WOULD
RECEIVE AN INCREASE AND CAL
FRESH BENEFITS.
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS TRAILER
BILL ALSO INCREASE THE COWARDS
MAXIMUM AID PAYMENT LEVELS BY
10% EFFECTIVE APRIL FIRST OF
TWENTY NINETEEN IT ALSO
ESTABLISHES A COW WORKS HOME
VISITATION PILOT PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES UP PREGNANT WOMEN AND
FAMILIES WITH A CHILD UNDER THE
AGE OF TWO WITH HOME VISITATION
SERVICES.
WITH PRIORITY GIVEN TO FIRST
TIME PREGNANT WOMEN AND PARENTS
THE PROGRAM PROVIDES FUNDING FOR
COUNTIES TO CONTRACT THAT THE
EXISTING EVIDENCE BASED HOME
VISITING PROGRAMS.
AND OR CREATE THEIR OWN EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAMS BUT THAT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
MISTRUST I TO QUESTION ABOUT THE
PROVISION OF THIS TRAILER BILL
THAT WOULD.
ALLOW INDEPENDENT STUDY HOURS TO
COUNT TOWARDS THE WELFARE TO
WORK REQUIREMENT FOR CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS SO.
CURRENT STATE LAW COUNTS
CLASSROOM HOURS IN DEGREE
GRANTING PROGRAMS AND
CERTIFICATE GRANTING PROGRAMS.
BUT I'M.
WONDERING IF YOU HAVE ANY
CONCERNS THAT ALLOWING SELF
REPORTED INDEPENDENT STUDY HOURS
TO COUNT WITH NO INDEPENDENT
VERIFICATION MECHANISM.
COULD RESULT IN GREATER FRAUD
AND CAL WORKS.
YEAH AND WOOD DEPARTMENT FINANCE
WE DON'T HAVE ANY DATA TO
SUGGEST THAT THAT WOULD OCCUR --
BUT MINOR SAYING THAT THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH OF WHAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE WHAT WE DID COUCH
REFORM AND IN THE NINETIES.
THIS ASSAY NOT ACCOUNTED --
FOR BUT TO OUR KNOWLEDGE WE
DON'T THINK THAT THAT WOULD
HAPPEN.
OKAY SO IF A COUNTY THESE ARE
SELF REPORTED NUMBERS THERE'S NO
INDEPENDENT VERIFICATION SO FOR
COUNTY.
IN ADMINISTERING CAL WORKS
WANTED TO CONTEST SOMETHING THAT
WAS REPORTED HOW WOULD THEY GO
ABOUT DOING THAT.
MY CORPORATE GUY THE LOCALS GOOD
IS A BETWEEN ECOLOGY OR TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE INFORMATIONS
THAT PROVIDER ACCURATE.
I MEAN HOW WHAT THE COLLEGE
NOTES SELF REPORTED BY THE
RECIPIENT.
I I THINK THE KEY THING IS THAT
THIS IS YOU KNOW BUILT ON TRUST
AND THAT THE CALVET INDIVIDUALS
WOULD.
DO IT IS APPROPRIATE FOR OTHER
NEEDS TO ENSURE THAT YOU KNOW
ALL THE HOURS THAT THERE.
USING A STUDY.
SHOULD WE CAN FOR AND PLUS AT
BUT BUT THEN THE DAY THERE'S
ONLY A MAXIMUM BOWERS TO SHOULD
BE ACCOUNT FOR OVER THERE.
IT'S NOT LIKE A REFINEMENT
CORRECTLY IT'S A THREE HOURS
ONLY. FOR PER CLASSES SO IT'S
NOT LIKE IT'S A WIDE RANGE OF
HOURS THAT YOU KNOW --
ANYBODY COULD ACCOUNT.
FOR OKAY LEVEL LARGER CONCERN
ABOUT THIS --
I THINK THAT PUBLIC PERCEPTION
OF CAL WORKS IS VERY IMPORTANT
AND I THINK THIS HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO UNDERMINE THE
PUBLIC'S TRUST AND CAL WORKS
BECAUSE IN ADDITION TO
POTENTIALLY INCREASING FRAUD --
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO VERIFY SO I
THAT I REAL PROBLEM WITH THAT
PART OF THE TRAILER BILL
[inaudible]
THICKNESS MATHIS.
MY MY QUESTION MY CONCERN OR
ALONG THE SAME LINES HERE
[inaudible]
WELL.
BUT YOU KNOW CAL WORKS IS GREAT
PROGRAM DOES A LOT. FOR FOR A
LOT OF FOLKS.
MY QUESTION MORE SHOW IS YOU
KNOW WHEN IT WHEN WE LOOK AT
ACCREDITATION HOURS.
YOU KNOW PART OF THAT WORKED
INTO IT IS HOW LONG THE WHOLE
WORK TAKES [inaudible]
IN SO.
SELF REPORTING UNIVERSES LOOKING
AT HOW MUCH.
YOU KNOW FROM TAKING A COURSE OR
SOMETHING OF COURSE THAT'S GOING
TO BE THREE CREDITS.
THE HOMEWORK HOURS READ
TYPICALLY WORKED INTO THAT I
KNOW WE HAVE SOME PEOPLE --
ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE THAT ARE
WITH HIGHER ED THOUGH TRY NO
MORE THAN --
NINETY BULL WIRE WE LOOKING AT
BASE UNIT OFF THE CREDIT HOURS
FOR THE CREDITS TAKING AND
GIVING THEM THE HALLMARK HOURS
INVASION THEIR VERSES A SELF
REPORTING.
I'M SORRY SIR I'M NOT SURE QUITE
SURE WILL TRY TO GET SO IN IN IN
WHEN YOU TAKE A COLLEGE COURSE
YOU CREATE EACH CREDITS WERE SO
MANY HOURS.
IN THE HOMEWORK IS INCLUDED IN
THAT.
WHY AREN'T WE TAKING THOSE
HOURS?
AND ADDING THAT. FOR FOR THE
COLLEGE CREDIT.
HOURS VERSES A SELF REPORTING
HOMEWORK HOURS.
THE BECAUSE THE HOMEWORK IS HIS.
TIED INTO HOW MANY.
HOURS THAT CREDITS WORTH.
SO WHAT ARE YOU BASING IT OFF OF
THE CREDITS TAKING IN AND HOW
MUCH.
HOME WORK HOURS IS ACCUMULATED
WITH THE CREDITS VERSES A SELF
REPORTING.
I DON'T KNOW THE EXACT HOURS
THAT ARE YOU THAT COULD BE
ACCOUNTED FOR THIS A FINER
CORRECTLY IT'S NOT LIKE THAT
IT'S IT'S ONLY THREE HOURS SO
FOR PER CLASSES BUT OUT THE COME
BACK.
NOW GET YOUR STAFF THE PROPER
INFORMATION --
BUT IT'S NOT LIKE.
IT'S ON AS THOUGH ANYBODY COULD
TO SAY THAT I'VE DONE AND OUR
TEN HOURS WORTH OF PER WEEK FOR
UPPER CLASS THERE IS THE LIMIT
THAT THEY COULD BE ACCOUNT
TOWARD.
THEIR WORK AROUND WHAT PLANTS
SO.
BUT THEN THE DAY THERE IS A
LIMIT NOBODY CAN GO UP THERE AND
SAY THAT --
THIS WHOLE WEEK I SPENT YOU KNOW
BURKE AND STUDY JUST FOR THIS
CLASS AND THERE'S A MAXIMUM
HOURS I COULD BE COUNT WITH A
WORK PLAN AYE I BRING IT UP
BECAUSE IT I MEAN THERE WE WE
HAVE A SOLID WAY OF COUNTING.
HOURS PER CREDIT IN AND HOW MUCH
HOMEWORK IS ASSIGNED TO THAT.
SO A AS A STATE IT JUST RAISES
THE QUESTION WHY WE ARE LOOKING
AT YOU KNOW IF IF A STUDENT
TAKING SO MANY CREDITS.
THOSE CREDITS WERE EQUAL TO A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF HOURS.
SO WHY WOULD WE BE BASED ON A
SYSTEM OFF OF SOMETHING THAT WE
KNOW.
IT OUR RD HAS AN EQUATION VERSES
A SELF REPORTING BACK.
THAT WAY THERE'S CLARITY IN
THERE THEN THERE IS A CONCERN
FOR FRAUD.
THAN WE ALREADY HAVE IT BASED
AND AND THAT WITH OUR STUDENTS
ARE ACTUALLY GETTING THE FULL
HOURS.
THEY SHOULD BE GETTING OF FOR
THE PROGRAM VERSES --
ELIMINATES LIKE YOU SAID THREE
HOURS.
YOU KNOW THREE HOURS FOR ONE
CLASS IS DIFFERENT THAN THREE
HOURS FOR ANOTHER CLASS.
LET ME THAT SOMETHING THAT WOULD
LOOK INTO AS FOR IMPLEMENTING US
WITH THE COUNTY AS YOU KNOW WITH
PARTS OF RESOURCES AND CONCERNS
IT'S MY AMP.
TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT YEAH YEAH
IT IS AUTOMATICALLY BRINGS OF
THE CONCERN THAT YOU KNOW NEXT
RIGHT AFTER AND CLEAN UP
LANGUAGE TO FIX THIS.
SO YOU KNOW MY AND MY OTHER
CONCERN TO USE EXCESSIVE MY
DISTRICT AND WE'RE WE'RE A 56%
MEDI CAL A LOT OF THOSE PEOPLE
ARE ALSO USING CAL WORKS OF
SOMETHING THAT TO TO GIVE AYE
AND BETTER THEMSELVES.
SO YOU KNOW TO MAKE SURE MY
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO GET THE HOURS
THE DESERVE.
BUT ALSO YOU KNOW WE HAVE
[inaudible]
THAT HALF CAN.
FRAUD BY BASING IT OFF OF THE
SYSTEM.
THE TARDY THERE.
I IN OF A CHARACTER'S PERMANENT
SUPPOSED TO HELP FOLKS BECOME
SELF SUFFICIENT AND AT AN
ABSOLUTE I'VE A LOT OF FRIENDS
AND FAMILY THEY'VE USED IT.
WHICH IS WHY MY CONCERN IN THIS
IS WHERE WE MAKING SURE THEY'RE
GETTING THE HOURS THAT THEIR DO
VERSES.
YOU KNOW SOME SELF REPORTING
MECHANISM THIS IS GONNA COST
TURMOIL.
AND LIKE THE WE COULD DEFINITELY
DO THAT INTO ACCOUNT AS WERE
IMPLEMENTED.
SEE HOW THAT GOES.
I I GUESS I'M.
CONFUSED BY THE COMMITTEE
DISCUSSION BECAUSE I'M NOT SURE
WHETHER.
YOU'RE ADVOCATING FOR MAKING IT
HARDER ARE MAKING IT.
EASIER SO YOUR CONSTITUENTS WITH
SO MISTER CHAIR I I WANNA MAKE
SURE IT'S EASIER BECAUSE IF IF
YOU'RE TAKING CREDITS THOSE
CREDITS.
COMBINED HOW MUCH CLASSROOM
HOURS AND HOMEWORK OUT.
AND WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IS NOW
IT'S GONNA BE SELF REPORTING.
SO WHY ARE WE JUST GIVEN A
STUDENTS THE HOURS FOR THEIR
CREDITS.
BECAUSE SOME OF THAT GOES INTO
THEIR HOME.
SO WE'REGONNA BASED OFF OF
THEIR HOMEWORK.
IT MAY BE DOCTOR WHATEVER.
OR FROM.
MR MEDINA CAN HELP WITH THIS.
WHY IT YOU WOULD THINK WE WOULD
BE SETTING UP A SYSTEM?
GUARANTEEING THEM THE HOURS THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GETTING FOR
THEIR CREDIT [inaudible]
VERSES.
LIMITING THEM TO TO THREE HOURS
IS IS A WRIST HOLE GOT AND I
THINK I THINK WE ARM.
AT WHY THINK WE'VE WE TOTALLY
AGREE WITH THAT MINDSET AND
TRYING TO MAKE IT MORE
STREAMLINED AND EASIER I THINK
THIS WAS THAT.
THE EFFORT WAS TO TRY TO MAKE IT
EASIER SO PER PERHAPS YOU KNOW
FINANCE COULD JUST DON'T DO IT
WITH THE SELF REPORTING IS GONNA
AT ANOTHER.
WELL IF TO IT WHERE WE ON THE
OLD BASED UPON CREDIT ASIAN AND
HOW MANY HOURS THEY'RE GETTING
GOTTA SEE YOUR TO SEE YOUR YOUR
YOUR POINT IS THAT.
THIS APPROACH IS AUTOMATICALLY
GET CREDITS WITHOUTHAVING TO
EVEN DO THE REPORTING IS THAT
WELL IF IF THEY'RE TAKING THE
CLASSES.
AND WE KNOW THAT HE HAS A CLASS
RESIDENTS ARE PASSING WORK.
CREATOR HAVING WE WE KNOW HOW
MUCH THOSE CREDITS ARE WORTH.
HOW MANY HOURS GOING TO THAT HOW
MANY HOME WORK HOURS GOING TO
THAT?
WOULD ONLY MAKE SENSE THAT WE
WOULD HAVE A SOLID SYSTEM VERSES
NOW THEY HAVE TO DO ONE MORE
STEP IN GOING TO SELF REPORTING.
ALL THE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
DOING CAL WORKS ARE.
A LOT OF THEM ARE.
WORKING A PART TIME JOB THEY'RE
GOING TO SCHOOL THE TRANSIT CARE
THEIR KIDS TRYING TO BETTER
THEMSELVES SO NOW WE'RE GONNA
ONE MORE BURDEN ON THEM.
WHEN WE ALREADY KNOW WHAT THE
CREDIT ASIAN HOURS ALL?
I THINK IT'S A FAIR POINT AYE
AYE YEAH I THINK THIS IS AN
INTENT TO PLACE ANY BURNING ON
ANY OF THE CAPITA CHIP AND
OVERALL WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
NO OF THE HOURS THAT THERE ARE
BEING ACCOUNTED FOR AND THE PARK
PLAN SO THAT IT GIVES THEM MORE.
HOURS AND FOR PURPOSES OF YOU
KNOW DON'T WANT WELFARE TO WORK
ACTIVITIES AN ACCOUNT FOR THAT
SO IT'S THEN INTENT BY MINOR
SENATE SITES KNOWNMEANS.
TO MAKE IT MORE COMPLICATED FOR
THE ACCOUNT WHICH RECIPIENT YEAH
THAT WILL THE CURRENT SYSTEM WE
COUNT THE HOURS IN THE CLASSROOM
[inaudible]
NOT.
WHAT THE PROBLEM SO WE NEEDED A
IS WE'RE DOING NEW SYSTEMS WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE?
WE WENT AGAIN WE KNOW HOW MUCH
THE ACCREDITATION HOURS OR IN
THE HOMEWORK IS IN OURS ARE
INCLUDED INTO THAT ON AN
ACCREDITATION SITE. FOR FOR
COLLEGE CREDITS AND WITH CAL
WORKS ONLY GIVING THEM THE HOURS
IN THE CLASSROOM.
WE ALREADY KNOW ON THE
ACCREDITATION SITE HOW MUCH
HOMEWORK HOURS WERE INCLUDED.
SO WE'RE GOING TO BALANCE THAT
OUT ON THE CAL WORKS SIDE WHERE
WE JUST TAKE A NUMBER FROM THE
ACCREDITATION CITING GIVEN NOT
TO THE VERSES A SELF REPORTING
MECHANISM.
IT'S GOING [inaudible]
TO CREATE QUESTIONS.
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK WE DO HERE.
AYE I THINK IT'S A GREAT POINT
AND I THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT AND
SOMEONE AGAIN NEXT YEAR I THINK
FAIR FAIR POINT.
ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY SEEN ON ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. HIT FOR FIVE
THERE COULD AFTERNOON KEVIN
NOTHING COALITION CALIFORNIA.
WELFARE RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
RELATIVE TO YOUR PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION [inaudible]
CURRENTLY.
IF YOU HAVE A WELFARE TO WORK
PLAN YOU HAVE TWELVE UNITS.
YOU AUTOMATICALLY GET TWELVE
HOURS OF STUDY TIME.
PREVIOUSLY FOR THOU FINISHER
PROGRAMS.
THE STUDY TIME THERE AND APPLY.
THIS IS TO EQUALIZE THE PLAYING
FIELD.
THEN GIVE THE SAME STUDY TIME.
A SELF INITIATED PROGRAMS THAT
IS AVAILABLE TO FOLKS WITH THE
REGULAR WELFARE TO WORK PROGRAM.
THE SELF FINISHES PEOPLE WERE IN
COLLEGE WHEN THEY APPLY FOR
WELFARE.
THEY COULD CONTINUE TO GO TO
COLLEGE RATHER THAN DROPPING
OUT.
THE OTHER TYPE IS.
GOING APPLY YOU GOT A JOB CLUB
AND THEN YOU GO SEE WORKER.
THEN THEY SEND YOU TO COLLEGE.
THREE IF YOU GO IF YOU WANT TO
LARA VERSION YOU GOT THE STUDY
TIME THE FORMER VERSION.
YOU CAN GET THE STUDY TIME.
WHICH WAS KIND OF NUTS.
SO WE JUST TRY TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR FOLKS. TO ACHIEVE SELF
SUFFICIENCY.
THAT'S A PROBLEM THAT YOU KNOW
--
IT ALSO WOULDN'T SO SAY THAT WE
SUPPORT.
THE 10% INCREASE WE SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
KATHY SANDERLING WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
WERE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATION THE BILL MAKES
REALLY IMPORTANT INVESTMENTS
TOWARD.
REDUCING IN SOME CASES ENDING A
PARTICULAR DEEP POVERTY AND THE
CAL WORKS PROGRAM FOR CHILDREN
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK OF ALL OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
YOUR STAFF WITH US.
ON THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
AND URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
JUSTIN GARRETT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
JUST WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND ADMINISTRATION FOR
THEIR PARTNERSHIP WITH COUNTIES
IN CONSIDERATION OF CAN COUNTY
WORKLOAD ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ON
A NUMBER OF KEY ISSUES IN THIS
BILL.
I'M INCLUDING CONTINUING
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CCR A FORM
OF CCR -- OF
THE SS I CASH OUT OF THE HOME
SAFE PROGRAM THANK YOU.
CAN LOS REPRESENTING CHILDREN
NOW ONE EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL IN FRONT OF YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
AND TO YOUR COMMITTEE AND STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US ON CAL WORKS
ON VISITING PROPOSAL.
AND REALLY EXCITED TO SEE THE
FINAL PRODUCT THAT'S INCLUDING
HERE FOR YOU TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
OPPOSITION TO SB.
EIGHT FOUR FIVE S. ARTIST AND
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WALKING
DOWN THE HALL.
OKAY A S. B. IT FOR SIX PUBLIC
SAFETY [inaudible]
I THINK.
THANK YOU THIS IS OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY TRAILER BILL NEW RESEARCH
ON BRAIN DEVELOPMENT AND
JUVENILE CASE LAW AROUND
DIMINISH CULPABILITY OF JUVENILE
OFFENDERS HAS PROMPTED THE
FOLLOWING CHANGES INCLUDED IN
THIS TRAILER BILL.
ALLOWS MORE TIME FOR YOU THREE A
BILL TATIAN AN APPROPRIATE
SETTING BY RAISING THE AGE OF
JURISDICTION FROM JUVENILE COURT
COMMITMENTS TO CDC OURS DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE FROM THE AGE
OF TWENTY THREE TO TWENTY FIVE
IT RAISES THE AGE OF CONFINEMENT
FOR ADULT.
DJJ FROM AGE TWENTY ONE TO
TWENTY FIVE AND CREATES A PILOT
PROGRAM TO HOUSE UP TO SEVENTY
SIX YOUNG ADULTS AT DJJ WHO
WOULD OTHERWISE SERVE THEIR
SENTENCES AN ADULT PRISON.
THIS BILL ALSO EXPANDS PEACE
OFFICER CADET TRAINING IN THE
ACADEMY FROM TWELVE TO THIRTEEN
WEEKS.
AND IN RESPONSE TO A DECLINE
PRISON POPULATION THE BILL
IDENTIFIES PRIORITIES FOR THE
REDUCTION OF VARIOUS OFFENDER
HOUSING AT CAPACITY WITHOUT
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SAYING NO COMMENT FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS REPUBLICAN
SUPPORT OF THE SPEED FOR SEX.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC OPPOSED TO
SB EIGHT FORCE [inaudible]
ANYBODY [inaudible]
OKAY.
SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENT WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO SB EIGHT FOUR
SEVEN OR COURTS STRIP.
I THINK THIS IS OUR COURTS I
TRAILER BILL AND THE BILL
INCLUDES LANGUAGE TO IMPLEMENT
AN ONLINE EDUCATION PILOT
PROGRAM FOR MINOR TRAFFIC.
BEGIN MOVING TOWARD A CIVIL
MODEL FOR ADJUDICATION OF MINOR
TRAFFIC VIOLATIONS.
THE TRAILER BILL ALSO INCLUDES
LANGUAGE REQUIRING THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO SUBMIT A LONG TERM
FUND CONDITION STATEMENT WITH
ANY FUTURE FUNDING REQUEST FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT THERE IS SUFFICIENT.
REVENUE TO FULLY SUPPORT ALL
EXISTING DEBT OR CAPITAL OUTLAY
OBLIGATIONS AS WELL AS THE FULL
PROJECT COST FOR THE PROPOSED
PROJECT FOR WHICH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL REQUEST FUNDING.
WITHOUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
VICKI WAS OR NOT.
THEY WAS CHAIR OBVIOUSLY YOU
KNOW I'M PASSIONATE ABOUT THE
ISSUE OF JUDGESHIPS CALIFORNIANS
ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE FACT
WERE FUNDING TO ADDITIONAL.
SPARE COURT JUDGES AND ONE
APPELLATE JUDGE --
HOWEVER WILL DISAPPOINTED THAT.
I AFTER THE DISCUSSION THAT WE
HAD IN CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
THAT.
I WE ARE ALLOCATING THESE
JUDGESHIPS TO SEE A SPECIFIC.
SUPERIOR COURT RATHER THAN AS WE
HAVE DONE IN THE PAST USING THE
JUDICIAL COUNCILS WORKLOAD
ALLOCATION FORMULA TO FIGURE OUT
WHICH COURTS THEY NEED TO GO TO
SO WHAT WAS THE RATIONALE AND IN
HAVING THE LEGISLATURE USE THIS
AS A POLITICAL.
TOOL AND DECIDE WHAT PORTS THEY
GO.
TO COUNSEL ALLOCATE THEM.
WE DID HAVE A LENGTHY DISCUSSION
ON THIS MATTER AND I WOULD SAY
I'M AS IS THE CASE WITH SEVERAL
OF THE BILLS THIS REPRESENTS AN
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP.
ON AND WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS
CONVERSATIONS OVER THE YEAR
ABOUT --
OVER THE YEARS ABOUT RIVERSIDE
CAPACITY AS WELL [inaudible]
ALRIGHT WELL --
SABATINO IS IS OUT OBVIOUSLY
ALSO HAS A AGREED JUDICIAL NEED
IN A STATEWIDE I MEAN WITH THESE
RELEGATED TO ADDITIONAL
JUDGESHIPS THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
SAYS JUST TO MEET OUR CURRENT
NEED WE HAVE ABOUT.
A HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE THAT ARE
NEEDED SO I'M VERY HOPEFUL THAT
IN FUTURE YEARS WE CAN TAKE
ANOTHER LOOK AT THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE I IT'S GOING TO GET
WORSE AND WORSE IF WE DON'T ACT.
THANK YOU MISTRESS.
I DO WANT TO JOIN --
WHERE THE SOMETHING MEMBER
OBERNOLTE SPECIFICALLY ON THE
ISSUE OF SALMON A DINO?
A JUDGE SHIPS THE THE NEED IN
SANDRA DINO IS JUST AS GREAT.
AS IT IS AND RIVERSIDE WHERE WE
ARE FIFTY JUDGES SHORT OUT.
AS A RIVERSIDE IS FORTY NINE
SHORT AND I HOPE THAT.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS GOING
TO BE LOOKED AT THE NEXT
[inaudible]
BUDGET.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA.
I I WOULD --
JOIN MY COLLEAGUES AND KNOWING
THAT THE NEED IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE.
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND SOBERED
AND YOU KNOW IS GREAT --
AND AND I HOPE TO SEE --
FUTURE JUDGES ARE THANKFUL FOR
THE TWO JUDGES THAT ARE.
HERE IN THE BUDGET FOR RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING JUDGES ADDED.
AND ASSEMBLY NO COUNTY AS WELL.
THANK YOU BACK TO THE CAN
ANYBODY ELSE.
OKAY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
EIGHT FOUR SEVEN MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC OPPOSED TO SB --
EIGHT FOUR SEVEN OKAY SEEING NO
FURTHER COMMENT WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD TO SB EIGHT SIX ONE NO
PLACE LIKE HOME MISCAST.
THINK YOU THIS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SUBMITS THE NO PLACE
LIKE HOME PROGRAM TO THE VOTERS
THAT THE NOVEMBER SIXTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN STATEWIDE GENERAL
ELECTION.
THE PROGRAM DEDICATES UP TO TWO
MILLION TWO BILLION EXCUSE ME
AND BONDS FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR
PERSONS WITH MENTAL ILLNESS WHO
ARE HOMELESS OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS.
PINNING VALIDATION OF THE
PROGRAM'S USE OF PROP SIXTY
THREE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
FUNDS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MANY COME.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC A SUPPORT OF S. B..
EIGHT SIX ONE MANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC OPPOSED S. B..
EIGHT SIX ONE OKAY MOVE MOVING
ON WILL GO TO SB EIGHT SUCCESS
THIS IS OUR THIRD GENERAL
GOVERNMENT TRAILER BILL
DISCUSSED.
THANK YOU OF THIS GENERAL
GOVERNMENT TRAILER BILL A
CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW
CONCERNING PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
OBLIGATION AND TO ENGAGE IN DUES
DEDUCTION AND ALSO CONTAINS
SEVERAL PROVISIONS RELATED TO
THE CIVIL SERVICE IMPROVEMENT.
UPDATE STATUTES CONSISTENT WITH
THE STATEPERSONNEL BOARD RULES
AND ARE PRIMARILY RELATED TO
IMPROVING EMPLOYMENT LESS EXAMS
AND APPOINTMENTS AND THE LIMITED
EXAMINATION AN APPOINTMENT
PROGRAM.
IT ALSO ESTABLISHES THE
AUTHORITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES TO REQUEST TO
RETIRE REMEMBER INFORMATION AND
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT SYSTEM CAN
PROVIDE RETIREE CENSUS DATA. TO
CALIPHATES ARE.
LASTLY I HAD THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES VARIOUS REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ACCOUNT CENSUS WITHOUT I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
MISTER FOX.
I WONDER IF YOU COULD GIVE ME
SOME UP BACKGROUND OR I SHOULD
SOME LIGHT IN THE PROVISION THAT
AFFECTS.
THE CURRENT MEDICAL OCCURRED
MEDICAL IN TERMS OF THEIR HOSPO
THIRTY MYERS JENNINGS AND TWENTY
FOURTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SIX CREATE THE CURRENT HEALTH
AUTHORITY --
AND THAT NOW THERE'S A PROVISION
--
IN THIS BUDGET TRAILER THAT
BASICALLY FORCES EMPLOYEES INTO
A CASE ERA AGAINST THE AGAINST
THE WILL OF THE CURRENT UP HER
MEDICAL.
THERE IS A PROVISION IN THIS
GENERAL GOVERNMENT TRAILER BILL
THAT PROSPECTIVELY OUT REQUIRES
EMPLOYEES HIRED BY THE KERN
COUNTY HOSPITAL AUTHORITY I HAD
TO BE A MEMBER.
OF THE KERN COUNTY EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT ASSOCIATION TO THE
EXTENT PERMITTED IN THE
APPLICABLE AMMO YOU.
WAS THIS PROVISION DID IT HAVE
INPUT FROM KERN MEDICAL OR THE
CAR AT THE COUNTY OF KERN.
WE DON'T BELIEVE SO [inaudible]
SO THEN.
I GUESS MAYBE IT.
EXPLAINED TO ME THEN.
HOW THIS BUDGET?
OTHERS PROVISION MAKES SENSE IF
THE TO THE BIGGEST STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVEMENTS PROCESS WERE NOT.
ALLOWED TO PROVIDE INPUT.
I'M AS I'VE STATED PREVIOUSLY
MANY OF THE PROVISIONS
THROUGHOUT THE BILLS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE ARE REPRESENTATIVE OF
AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP IN THIS PROVISION AS
ONE AND IT WAS THIS PROVISION
DISCUSS WITH THE AUTHOR OF AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX DID THE
AUTHOR OF THE ORIGINAL.
CURRENT HEALTH AUTHORITY DID HE
SIGNED OFF ON THIS.
AND AS SOME MISS COSTS ALREADY
YEAH.
MY APOLOGIES SOME OF ONE SYSTEM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND WE ARE NOT AWARE OF THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT HAPPENED ON
WITH THE RELATED PARTIES.
BUT MY CONCERN IS THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT OF COURSE IS IN
IT AT A LOCAL ISSUE --
IN TERMS OF THAT DISCUSSION
BETWEEN COUNTY OF KERN THE KERN
MEDICAL --
AND OF COURSE THE EMPLOYEES --
DOWN IN KERN COUNTY --
MANY OF WHERE REPRESENT AND SO
IT SEEMS TO GREATEST CONCERN TO
ME THAT THE BUDGET PROCESS IS
BEING [inaudible] TO SWAY ONE
SIDE OR THE OTHER AGAINST THE
WILL OF A LOCAL THE LOCAL FOR A
STAKEHOLDERS THAT HAVE THE
BIGGEST --
INPUT HAD TO BE PROVIDED IN THIS
SITUATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE COMMENTS.
OKAY SEEING NOT ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT IS SUPPORT.
IT OR ON BEHALF OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
AND I CAN ANSWER SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I THINK WE'RE
JUST ASKED BY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE WERE.
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN THE
DISCUSSION AROUND KERN A MEDICAL
CENTER WE BELIEVE ACTUALLY THE
AGREEMENT YOU SEE IN THE BUDGET
WAS VERY CONSISTENT WITH THE
INTENTIONS OF THE PROPOSAL.
AND AB TWENTY SIX FORTY SIX AM
THE GOAL OF THIS PROPOSAL IN THE
BUDGET IS TO PROVIDE PARITY TO
NEW EMPLOYEES THAT ARE COMING
INTO KERN MEDICAL CENTER.
THAT SAME ABILITY FOR THEM TO
HAVE PENSIONS LIKE EMPLOYEES
THAT ARE IN THE KERN MEDICAL
CENTER RIGHT NOW RIGHT NOW
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
LOOPHOLE SO THAT NEW EMPLOYEES
ARE NOT GOING TO GET THE SAME
BENEFIT.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE BILL AND PROVIDES
PARITY AMONGST THE EMPLOYEES
ACROSS KERN MEDICAL CENTER TO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PUT MONEY
INTO THEIR PENSIONS MISS.
FOR JUST ONE QUICK QUESTION DID
YOU -- IT
DID YOU ARE A FOLKS THAT YOU ARE
WITH THESE YOU DISCUSS THIS WITH
THAT THE AUTHOR OF TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR BY FIVE FORTY SIX
AND THE AUTHOR AMENABLE TO THESE
CHANGES YES THERE'S BEEN
DISCUSSIONS I THINK WITH PEOPLE
ACROSS THE BOARD OBVIOUSLY
NEGOTIATIONS ARE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE.
LEADERSHIP AMEND FOLKS HERE BUT
THERE'S BEEN CONVERSATIONS FOR A
LONG TIME ABOUT THE CONCERNS
ABOUT KERN MEDICAL CENTER
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE PENSION
PROBLEMS WE BELIEVE THIS WAS A
PLACE TO LAND IN THE MIDDLE
GROUND. TO RELEASE CARRY THIS
OVER INTO THE JULY FIRST STATE
WHEN WE EXPECT THE AMMO YOU TO
BE DECIDED UPON.
SO JUST TO CLARIFY THEN THE
AUTHOR OF THE ORIGINAL AUTHOR OF
THIS THAT THINK THE CREATION OF
CURRENT HEALTH AUTHORITY HE
SUPPORTS THIS PROVISION.
HE'S BEEN ENGAGE IN DISCUSSIONS
I BELIEVE SO SO YOU HAVE TO ASK
THE AUTHOR DIRECTLY THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CAITLYN VEGA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION WE
ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
TRAILER BILL WE THINK IT
CONTAINS SOME IMPORTANT
PROTECTIONS.
THAT STREAMLINE AND IMPROVE
PUBLIC SECTOR LABOR RELATIONS
THANK YOU.
MICHELLE CAST OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION WE
TO SUPPORT THIS I'M TRAILER BILL
THEIR SUPPORT MEASURES IN HERE
WILL HELP MAINTAIN --
LABOR RELATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
THINK YOU.
CHRISTY BROWN BEHALF CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS THE MACHINISTS' AYE F.
PT LOCAL TWENTY ONE AND THE
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION
SUPPORT.
SAYS IDEAS A BEHALF THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JOSH WILL GO GOOD WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
AND STRONG SUPPORT. SEVEN BROWN
BUT HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
JONATHAN LIGHTMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
SUPPORT.
RICHARD MARX AND ON BEHALF OF
THE WESTERN ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION AND
SEVERAL OTHER CONTRACTOR GROUPS.
OF WERE ACTUALLY IN OPPOSITION A
TO PROVISION IN THE BILL --
AND IT'S THE COMPOSITION OF THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE --
FOR THE PRE RELEASE CONSTRUCTION
TRADE CERTIFICATE PROGRAM A IT'S
VERY SLANTED WERE OPPOSED TO THE
LANGUAGE WE'VE A SUGGESTED SOME
CORRECTIVE AMENDMENTS TO MKE IT
NEUTRAL OUT WERE OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION WE
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
STATE FED HERE IN SUPPORT.
THINK ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT.
THEM MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION.
S. B. AT SIX SIX HEATHER
WHITESTONE WITH THE KERN COUNTY
HOSPITAL AUTHORITY IN CURRENT
MEDICAL.
AND THIS THIS CHANGE WOULD HAVE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT TO OUR
OPERATIONS BOTH FINANCIALLY
STRATEGICALLY.
WE ARE CURRENTLY IN OUR AMMO YOU
NEGOTIATIONS HAVE WITH OUR
MEMBER REPRESENTATIVES.
AND THIS WAS DONE WITHOUT ANY
INPUT FROM ANY OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS HAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FONG INDICATED.
I'M IN OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL HE WAS
NOT AWARE OF THESE CHANGES UNTIL
WE MADE HIM AWARE OF THOSE
CHANGES.
I WHICH FOR US --
CAUSE CONCERN IS TO THE
PRESENTATION OF THIS IS TO
CLARIFY INTENT.
I THAT LANGUAGE WAS PRETTY
POSING CRAFTED WITHOUT ANY
INVOLVEMENT IT CREATES CONFUSION
AND AMBIGUITY ON THE TREATMENT
GROUPS OF EMPLOYEES.
AND IT DOES NOT CONSIDER
EMPLOYEES NOT CURRENTLY COVERED
BY MEMBER OF A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING.
AND I'M AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS TRAILER BILL.
THANK YOU NOBODY ELSE IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B..
EIGHT SIX SIX OKAY SCREEN NO
FURTHER COMMENT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE.
TO S. B. EIGHT SEVEN ONE FILM
TAX CREDIT.
I THINK I THINK YOU AYE THIS IS
A FILM TAX CREDIT EXTENSION THE
SECTION EXTENDS THE FILM TAX
CREDIT FOR FIVE YEARS AT THREE
AND THIRTY MILLION PER YEAR AND
ALLOCATIONS FROM JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE PROGRAM
PROVIDES TAX CREDITS ON A
COMPETITIVE.
BASIS FOR FILM PRODUCTION TO
ENCOURAGE FILM PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA.
REVENUE LOSSES OF THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS ARE EXPECTED IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND WILL INCREASE
THEREAFTER AS THE TAX CREDIT
UTILIZATION INCREASES.
THANK YOU INSTRUMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NOT A
QUESTION AS MUCH AS A COMMENT I
I SUPPORT THIS TAX CREDIT I
SUPPORTED WHEN WE EXTENDED TWO
YEARS AGO AND I VOTED FOR IT IN
COMMITTEE --
HOWEVER IF WE ARE IN AGREEMENT
THAT IT'S NECESSARY TO EXTEND A
TAX CREDIT TO HOLLYWOOD TO KEEP.
FILMING HERE IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF OUR BUSINESS CLIMATE
IN THE STATE.
WOULDN'T IT MAKE MORE SENSE TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THINGS THAT
IMPROVE THE BUSINESS CLIMATE
HERE BECAUSE IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
EXTEND TAX CREDITS TO EVERY
SINGLE INDUSTRY THAT WE WANNA
RETAIN HERE.
BUT HAVING SAID THAT THE ALEJO'S
FOUND THAT THIS IS EFFECTIVE AND
IN KEEPING FILMING HERE IN
CALIFORNIANS ARE SUPPORTED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY OTHER
[inaudible]
COMMENT --
MEMBERS REPUBLICAN SUPPORT OF
SB.
EIGHT SEVEN ONE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
ISSUE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST TERRY
THOMAS ON BEHALF OF THE MOTION
PICTURE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF THEATER OWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA NEVADA.
AND WALT DISNEY COMPANY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JEAN URBAN REPRESENTING
DIRECTORS GUILD OF AMERICA WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE IDEA
LEGISLATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORTS.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS INSIDE AFTER AND
SPORT.
JON ROSS ON BEHALF OF
NBCUNIVERSAL IN SUPPORT.
THINK ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
S. B..
EIGHT SEVEN ONE ANY OPPOSITION
DISPUTES ON ONE OKAY SAY NOT.
SEEING NO FURTHER ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA WE WILL ADJOURN